Alright, let's get into hatred mail for the
week. We are going, you know, we've had a
lot of hatred mail related to a lot of timely
things about Trump and so on and so forth.
Today we're going back to an old faithful
in hatred mail. But first quick reminder about
what hatred that mail is.
Brace yourselves for the only information
that can successfully penetrate a 10 foil
hat
[inaudible]
Patriot mail written by Patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom.
All right, so here it is, just going back
to old fashioned antisemitic conspiracy theories.
Let's take a listen.
Hmm. A Jew is running the David Pakman show.
What a coincidence. You soft spoken stupid
passive aggressive idiots Pacman who probably
thinks that Holocaust happened to the Jews.
You have a million subscribers, which this
Jewish owned platform owned by Google's Jewish
owners and run by a Jewish woman that is promoted
you to get more exposure based on you being
a liberal and a Jew
has in Holocaust denial just sort of become
kind of boring like at this point is, is that
really where you're going to put your eggs
in the basket of patriotism? I just don't
know. And of course, if you're not familiar,
and I envy you if you just don't know about
this, a lot of conspiracy theories about,
um, you know, the Jewish conspiracy to control
media and that's what is being implied by
Ola Jew running the David Pakman show. What
a coincidence. Wow. Don't fall for hatred.
Statism fight against it. With the coupon
code hatred at 40, the coupon code hatred
40 saves you 40% off of membership and it
is a middle finger proverbially, metaphorically
a to the hatred. It is spelled H, a T R I
O T four zero. It saves you 40% off of any
membership@joinedpacman.com and the hatred
IOTs hate it because the hatreds want to hurt
the show.
And when hatred at 40 is used for memberships,
Patriots know that they're a, the futility
of their hatred mail.